- So, Hany and I, we've
known each other for,
I don't know, 15, 20 years.
And, we want to jumpstart
the social media thing.
We want to basically just come
here and just talk to you.
- Sure.
- Like you know what we have going on.
- Uh-huh.
- And, just hear your thoughts.
- Cool.
- A little bit about me.
I met my wife at 14, met this guy at 14.
- You figured it all out at 14.
- Right.
- Well, I started working
at the front desk at 14.
I've had one job, one girlfriend.
She turned into my wife and
then I followed my passion,
opened up a business, which,
you know, I opened up gyms.
So, now we have 20 gyms globally.
We do 50%.
- And, do you franchise?
Oh, got it.
- So, 50% is corporate.
- Thank you, thanks love.
- With different companies,
and then the other 50%
is our regular gyms
that we own and operate.
We have Mexico, different locations.
- So, you have 10 gyms
that you own and operate.
- Mhm-mm.
- And, 10 that are more.
- More or less.
- More or less, nine, eight.
- Eight, yeah right.
- You have eight that you own?
- Yeah, so Cabo and then
the Bay Area, right.
And, then the rest are corporate wellness.
So, for example, if you wanted to bring in
group style training, we
specialize in that, right.
- So, you build gyms within organizations.
- Correct, 'cause basically our theory is.
- I got it.
- What I thought was that it was broken.
So, I started the gym back in 2008,
and I saw people getting engaged,
becoming best friends, everything.
I figured, there's nothing
better for your company.
- I totally get it.
And, see the way we work is
building inside of companies,
that whole concept.
I think of Beener that way.
- Yeah.
- I think Beener building
marketing departments
within companies is like a good idea.
- Yeah, and so.
- So, I get that.
- For us we use exercise as a
way to break down the barrier,
had the CEO working
next door to the intern.
So, in 2008 I opened our first gym,
a thousand square feet and it
just grew, grew, grew, grew.
No outside funding,
owner-operated 100% ourselves.
We have 150 employees.
I started competing at the
Crossfit games in 2008,
won the Crossfit games.
- Is that right?
- And, then I competed eight more times.
So, I've been--
- So, when you won the Crossfit games,
was that the first time
you got it put on publicly?
- Yeah, no so that was the second year
of the Crossfit games.
I won it and after that,
it kinda catapulted a bunch of stuff.
So, I took a first, a fifth.
I've been on the podium multiple times.
Been Team USA three times.
I'm as decorated as you
can get in that area,
but I grew the business at the time
when I got into Crossfit.
There was no money there.
Now, because of endorsements and stuff,
there's a lot more money,
which has been good for me to have.
That I didn't have to rely on
anything outside the business.
- I understand.
- So, now I'm at a place,
here we are 10 years later.
My daughter got diagnosed
with leukemia two years ago,
it's changed everything.
- Everything.
- I took a year off of travel.
I used to travel 200
days a year, like you do.
I mean, you probably do more than that,
but I used to travel a lot.
Boom, it just instantly made
me change my perspective,
and I still obviously,
I was blessed to have good
people run the business,
but I didn't travel anymore.
Now that she's getting better,
I'm getting back on my travel routine.
You know, I wrote a book, but
I'm taking my time with it.
I talked to Tim Ferris a lot about this,
and he's just like dude you
don't have to write anything.
Wait until it's good and put it out
in the next couple of months,
but basically the theory about it is
is this concept of AMRAP mentality.
- What kind of mentality?
- AMRAP, so in fitness, there's
this thing called AMRAP.
I was talking to Jordan about it earlier,
which is as many rounds as possible,
and so the whole theory is like,
I think in this day and age,
people get distracted so easy.
Like, they'll be talking to you
but they'll be on their phone.
They'll be working, but
at home with their kids.
And, I think the whole theory
is that by incorporating
this AMRAP where you
AMRAP whatever you do.
Like, if I ask you to do as many pushups
as you can do in a minute,
that's all you're focused on.
And, so for me, I opened the business,
I was competing at the highest level,
I got married, had two
kids, started asking myself
how do I balance these different things,
but also thrive in them.
And, so the theory was
just segmenting my day
and being present and focused
in whatever I was doing.
But, not being home because the
story goes, I'm with my kids
- You're preaching.
- Preaching to the choir.
- You're preaching to the choir.
I mean, I get a lot of pushback
from my work-life balance.
I'm like, cool you feel
good about yourself
that you're coming home at
seven, but you're on your phone
and like, I'm complete divide and conquer.
- That's right.
- I take seven weeks of
vacation, which is a lot
by workaholic standards,
but that's how I do it.
- That's right.
- I call it winning in extremes.
I'm all in.
- And, it's like, you're
all in in mentality.
Obviously, we follow you.
We know exactly who
you are and everything.
Everything in your book
is exactly what lies
in my methodology.
- That's cool.
- I believe to be ethical,
and from what I hear about you
from the different
people, I don't know you.
It's not the front, who
you are is who you are.
- Yeah.
- Especially how some people--
- Of course I know.
It's why I like meeting people.
It only helps me in a lot of ways, right?
Because the closer people are,
the more the truth gets exposed.
- That's right.
And, so for me again,
I share this, because.
- You're giving me a framework.
You're giving me context, that's good.
- I have these different things going on,
created this concept of AMRAP mentality.
- So, is your, I'm listening
and you can give me more,
but as a quick first question,
because you see a lot of
alignment in us, theoretically,
on a religious front, the religion of it.
You're curious on what my take might be
on a couple things that
you're pondering with.
- Yeah, more or less.
- Cool, makes sense.
- And, so I've given
AMRAP mentality talks.
I've done all different types of stuff.
- So, you wanna build your
world around this thesis?
- Well, yes, so I've
competed, I've done that
And, so I think that my
story is interesting.
I've had one wife, kids,
one with cancer at a young age, right?
- You've got all sorts of shit going on.
- And, so my perspective is unique.
- The good news is, honestly,
and I really believe this.
Listen, you've got clear cut things
that people would be interested in,
but I think everybody weirdly does.
Like, I'm seriously fascinated by it.
Like, the most niche, niche is what wins
and the most niche
thing is being a person.
- Just being alive.
- Just being fucking alive, dude.
Like, it's crazy, my sister
put a rock up her nose at six.
It is like an unbelievably
interesting moment in her life.
It's pretty subtle, compared
to one wife, you know, leukemia
but you could go all in on it.
- Right.
- You could.
You know, and so, I
believe that by the way.
So, I think you have things
that are more outwardly obvious,
but yeah, everybody's got ammo,
they just don't think some of their stuff.
Yours is obviously interesting,
but I think everything
is actually interesting.
I think that's the punchline
of this whole game.
- Well, yeah and I think to your point,
I just wanna get the message
out in a different way.
So, for years I messaged
Fitness and teaching movement,
I'm a subject control expert
in this particular field
of fitness.
- So, look, I've captured enough already,
you're gonna like this, it's gonna get to
the more, I understand, I think, already,
so let me ask you a real question.
Really, I think I do.
- No, I think you do, too.
- I think, so.
Are you trying to get as
much awareness as possible
to then just give you leverage to give you
whatever may come up in your ambitions?
- Yeah.
- And you believe that
that is through building
more personal brand awareness?
- Yeah.
- Good.
And so where do you sit in
the world that I sit in?
Like, how far along are you in?
- The journey?
Not as far as you, obviously.
- That's fine.
- I think Instagram, not bad.
- And so where do you sit
in this whole lexicon?
- Right now, so when he first started
I basically helped him put
the paint on first walls
of the first gym.
And so, with him for a few
years, decided to do my own thing
long story short came back,
now I help him out with
apparel and his personal
brand outside the company.
- Yes, I understand.
You're the business partner,
you're the business teammate of him.
- [Together] Yeah.
- I understand.
- And, so, where he's at right now
is that he created this huge following
back in the day, so like 2008.
- And where did it live?
In the ethos?
- On social, so YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram,
his channels blew up immediately
because he had just
won the Crossfit Games,
people wanted to start following him,
popularity was skyrocketing, right?
- But you were taking all that energy
and putting it into the
gyms, instead of the brand.
It makes sense, it's 2008.
- So, for example is that he has 50,000
followers on YouTube, but
we only get a few hundred
hits on videos, so, we're
feeling just stale right now.
We're trying to reactivare this.
- You know what's amazing?
This will get you very excited.
I don't think I was much further along
three and a half years
ago when I got serious.
Like I had my thing, I was winning,
good things were happening,
but I think I was at 48,000
subscribers on YouTube.
I was at 34,000 Instagram followers.
I was big on Twitter, because
that's where I come from.
But I was, head-down in building Beener.
I got rebooted, D-rock
started three years ago?
I got rebooted somewhere
in like three and a half,
four years ago, and it
happened really fast.
So, it's funny, I think I was in a very.
Like, I'm in a very good spot right now,
but like, three and a
half, four years ago,
I was in a stale spot.
For personal brand.
- Right.
And that's, to his point,
the company's grown.
And we have a brick and
mortar that's built on
actual stuff, right?
- Let me ask you, I
apologize for interrupting,
what do you want, let's say, I go
(snapping)
you've got 25 million
people truly following
you across the board,
where do you think you're
gonna put that attention?
Apparel?
- No, I think it would
be speaking engagements
and sharing the message,
like, what you're doing.
For me, especially my daughter being sick,
it's changed my whole mindset,
my perspective on things,
I've seen a lot of shitty shit.
And I think I want to
share the positivity,
and I also want to share
the message of hard work.
I don't know whatever happened to just
good old, roll up your
sleeves and just crush it.
And the way you start off is like,
dude, I slept on the floor
of our gym multiple times,
and I don't know where this,
especially in the bay area,
it's so like IPO, get rich
quick, it just doesn't happen.
You've gotta keep at it for a long time.
- So, that's where
you're at, right?
You love speaking.
- Yeah.
- Okay, please.
- And so, just to back up on the social.
Instagram, 420,000.
Twitter, Facebook, about 100,000 each.
- Excuse me for one
second, I'm just trying
to find us more time, give
me a couple more minutes.
Hold on one second.
Keep going.
- Between all the different channels,
there's different ways
we make money, obviously.
But what I'm inspired by is personal.
- How?
- So, our gyms make money, right?
We do about (Bleep) a year in revenue.
- That's great.
- So, that's fine.
- It's a real business.
- It's a real business, right.
We started a virtual business.
- I don't live in
Silicon Valley mentality.
(Bleep) dollars in revenue from scratch
is far more impressive than
99% of the shit I've seen
in Silicon Valley.
- And that's part of the reason,
I don't really talk numbers
much, but I know with you,
I just want to share with you real quick.
- You're giving me context.
- Right, context.
So we have that going on.
- Cool, next.
You feel like that gives you
the latitude of investing.
- Right, I had major
sponsorship deals with Reebok,
that paid my mortgage.
But for me, my wife and I,
just at an event yesterday,
raised 400 grand for pediatric cancer,
because we know Michael
Meena and different chefs,
so we brought them all together,
but we're about philanthropic,
we're about sharing the message
of hard work and being positive.
And that's the bigger picture.
- And then everything works out.
- Then you get paid
$150,000 to give a speech.
- Right, like, look.
Like you said, dude, I wanna buy the Jets.
Of course I wanna buy the Jets,
but I always want to do
good things along the way.
For me, do I want to send my
kids to the best colleges.
- So literally, a lot of
similarities to where I'm at.
- 100%, that's one of the reasons
why I followed up with you
five, six, seven times, because I'm like,
"Dude, I really want to meet you,"
and just share who I am.
- So I think there's a
lot of things running
through my mind.
You need to start thinking of yourself
as a media company.
It seems like you know
enough about me to know,
there's nothing I think
I'm going to tell you
that's maybe not something
you've ever heard before.
You need to have written,
audio and video formed content
being put out at scale every fuckin.
You have to understand, here's the thing.
It's a land-wrap.
Is it as easy to become a
Crossfit celebrity today
as it was in 2008?
No.
Supply and demand.
The supply and demand of
awareness and attention
in this device across the
11 platforms that matter
will never be better than it is right now,
and it's not as good as it was yesterday.
Got it?
So, that's all I've got to say.
From LinkedIn, corporate fitness content.
To fuckin a podcast, to all of it.
I think that, you know, how
long have you been following me?
- Years, he's.
- So I've been following
you for a long time now.
- Good, and you follow
Tim as well then, too?
- No.
- I've been following
both you guys for years.
- Good, so like, and other
people as well, right?
If you watch who get's hot, who gets when,
who gots what, like if you look
at the personalities that win,
we're never in the same spot.
This guy jumps this one,
this girl jumps that guy,
this guy goes down, this guy goes up.
It all happens based on who's best
at the thing that matters
the most at the time.
- Right, like Tim, podcast,
obviously he's crushing the game.
- That's right, killin' it.
And listen, Tim is so talented.
- He's one of the best
interviewers I ever.
- He's so talented.
Moments in time.
Instagram, podcasts, you know, LinkedIn,
I'm very bullish on.
All this stuff, like, you
have to have a podcast,
you have to have written form,
you have to have a vlog,
you have to have them.
- Yeah, so we just started
a vlog, but we didn't want
to bring a camera in
here because we didn't
feel like it was appropriate,
just out of respect for you.
- Always ask everybody, and
as long as you ask kindly,
like, for example, I would've said yes.
- 100%, we should've vlogged.
- No, I'm just giving you advice.
If you're gonna do a
vlog, I overthink it, too.
I almost didn't ask The Rock last week,
but then I did, and now we have it.
And that's good.
- I took a picture of something
you wrote in your book
the guy looks like a dick until he's a.
- Oh, right, right, everything looks,
until you don't.
- Right, and, that was pretty funny.
- Anyway, nonetheless, you
need to think of yourself
as a media company.
You need to think of yourself as ESPN,
not as a person, and then you
start thinking differently.
Then you're like oh, where's our blog?
The amount of content
you should be putting out
and spending money on,
my bigger thing is, based
on the two revenue streams
for you that are obviously
more substantial,
the gyms and the sponsorship.
How is the Crossfit
community health these days,
in relevance, or has
there been so many new
workout trends that it kind of like,
that's what I feel in the lexicon.
- Yeah, so, we were, we
started off as NorCal Crossfit,
ten years ago.
As the years have gone by, three years ago
we rebranded it NC Fit, as in NorCal fit.
- Right, smart.
- The reason for that is we wanted to be
in control of our own brand.
- Period.
- I didn't want to be attached to anything
that we didn't have any control over.
What happened is, Crossfit
put out some things
about guns, and look, whether
I'm pro or against it,
it's irrelevant, my business is neutral.
And so the problem is, because
we were attached to them,
we're in, we're in California.
It's like, dude, I realized
right there and then
that we lost the account at Twitter,
so we were servicing Twitter,
we were doing Crossfit there,
an executive came in and was like hey,
we're not gonna have a
Crossfit gym in here,
but we weren't just offering
Crossfit, a wide variety,
but the brand, so we had to rebrand it.
That's all we did.
So we have the app with the gyms,
we have the gyms, we have
the partnership income,
we have t-shirts and apparel,
we have another product
that we have that's
just like a workout mat,
there's multiple avenues
through the NC Fit,
through our company
that we make money from.
Long-term contracts with
corporate accounts, etc.
But the personal brand
is what I'm inspired by,
because I want to share the message.
- So how can I help you?
- We asked each other
this, like, what do we ask?
I think we just wanted to
come have a conversation.
- Yeah, look, listen, I don't
think anybody understands
how to build a personal
brand on February 26, 2018,
better than me right this second.
Tomorrow, I might see something, but look,
here's what I can tell you.
It's about, it's about
content that's scale,
and really investing in it.
You know, forget about even
your guys' relationship,
what's the additional 300,000
all the way down to 30,000
you know, to me, listen
to your brand, 300,000
and four people and add money
to take you to where you want.
I don't have a good sense
of, is that an expensive,
that's a lot of money,
so I don't think like,
spending 300,000 on your
personal brand is so easy
regardless of how well it's going,
but just listening, I would say hey,
hire four people at 50K a pop,
and spend $100,000, or
three people at 50K a pop
and 150,000 in Instagram,
and YouTube, and Podcast ads,
and I think you'll be in a very.
Like, if I tell you how to do it,
you'll be in a really fuckin' awesome spot
in a year where I think you
can make up that difference.
- The way you're thinking about things,
is the way we want to,
the nice thing is we have
this brick and mortar
but now it's time to, it's time to scale
the personal brand, which
I've been afraid to do
for a long time.
- I get it.
- Because, when you
put yourself out there,
it feels uncomfortable.
- Yeah, but once you make that.
Once you can get to the comfortable part,
it becomes the most important thing.
- From a messaging perspective,
I do have a question for you.
So you know, you have hustle there,
I kind of, I feel the same way, right?
- Two minutes.
- The hustle, the push,
this AMRAP mentality,
and it correlates with
a lot of fitness, right?
Translates really well.
- Even better brother, it's your truth.
You know, here's my thing.
If DHH and Jason Fried and Silicon Valley
get mad at me and write
articles that I'm bad
on Medium about hard work, and
it should be about balance,
that's their lives.
Mazel Tov that you grew
up in an Ivy League home,
and your parents paid for
Stanford, and like cool.
You should, and I'm in, and you should.
Here's what I know.
For everybody that's like me,
that grew up the way I did,
this is the answer.
As far as messaging, I
don't think about messaging.
That's how you get it.
Brother, that's the answer.
- Right, I overthink.
- Everybody does.
- February 26, 2018, one
reason, I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna speak my truth
all the way through,
and I know I'm a good
dude, so I can't lose.
Like, I might not be agreed on,
I might not even be deemed right now,
but I have a funny feeling
I know how it ends.
- Dude, well I mean, you've obviously,
you're proving the model right now.
You're the industry
leader, without a doubt.
And whenever you're an industry leader,
some people are gonna
be haters, but fuck em.
- Yeah, and honestly, I have empathy.
I know most people aren't gonna hate on me
if they know me at all for real,
and if they don't, like
I even have empathy,
like I don't know, the video
I just posted on Instagram
I was tough on that kid on stage,
it feels like I was
rude, but I could sense
that I needed to be rude to help him.
I just know what my intent is.
- Your intent is good and
people can pick up on that.
- Do you know how many people
in Silicon Valley are friends?
San Francisco, like, people
that you've worked with
use charity as a front to paint themselves
as a good person?
You know how much good shit
I do that I never talk about?
All of it, I don't talk about my family
or my charity work.
Doesn't mean I'm not doing it.
But I'm okay with that,
because I always say,
if an expose comes, and
people are like show us
your tax report, we have to see it,
I'll be like here you go.
So I don't overthink anything.
Definitely don't overthink it.
If you're as good of a
dude as you think you are,
it all works out.
- I am authentic to who I am.
- Me too, man, I got shortcomings.
That's all it comes down to.
As long as your shortcomings
aren't real shit,
that's why nobody wants
to build their brand,
cuz they're harassing people,
because they're stealing money,
because they're doing dumb shit.
(laughing)
- Right.
- You genuinely have no bad
in you, no bad intentions,
and you just put it all out there, yeah.
You're gonna end up somewhere good.
- That's why this is working for me.
I'm growing because the truth
is winning more and more.
- That's it.
Just putting out the
truth and how can people?
- As long as you're putting out the truth
and you have self-confidence,
and you're patient,
you're okay with people
saying you're full of shit.
- Everything I'm sitting
here telling you is 100%.
- I believe you.
And to me, it's like the
aha at the end, you know?
Like you win at the end.
I don't mind people booing
me in the third quarter.
- Cool, well we know you
have a ton of stuff to do.
Really appreciate your time.
It means a lot.
- Real pleasure.
I'll look for your guys' emails.
We'll talk, we'll be in touch.
We've got context now.
(light rock music)